after now you're an adult when you're
out there in the real world
if you don't talk to strangers you're
broke taking not stupid risk
but calculate the risk how can i use the
least amount of money
but get my business going so just
because the business fail
it doesn't mean you fail they're two
different things
need motivation watch a top 10 with
belief
[Music]
nation
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best dan lok and my take on his top 10
rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one focus on the market
to me market always comes first and
product comes
second i want to find out what are the
needs in the marketplace that are not
being
fueled that's not being filled i want to
see what problems are not being solved
i always say that every problem is a
product i want to find out
where are people frustrated about a
certain thing
now of course if you want to create a
new category you want to be a category
king
you want to be tapping into a blue ocean
that's something that no one's ever no
one's ever done that's perfectly fine if
that's your goal
but from my perspective most people
simply don't have their abilities
most people they are too green it takes
some skills to do that but if you this
is the first couple of businesses
you are much safer and wiser
just to see what's out there right now
what's already selling
what are people already searching for
let's say if you are selling something
online
what are people searching for and
already buying on
amazon what are people already buying
from other e-commerce sites
what are people buying in terms of
keyword research what what keywords are
they typing into
google they can easily go to google in
the the keyword tool that you can find
out
how much search volume are there are
people actively
looking for solutions to solve their
problems rule number two
expand your comfort zone when you're
growing up
what did your parents tell you don't
talk to strangers right
you're gonna get kidnapped right you're
gonna you're gonna be they're gonna do
something harmful to you
right so it's always growing up you you
have this
fear you develop this fear of oh i don't
want to talk to
to strangers it's very scary it's very
very dangerous
well guess what after now you're an
adult when you're out there in the real
world
if you don't talk to strangers you're
broke in fact i
say the amount of success the amount of
money
is in direct proportion to how many
strangers that you talk to
every single day because in business
what is it all about it is about
getting attention number one after
getting attention is turning a stranger
into a friend turning a friend into a
customer in the customer
to a raving fan that's what business is
all about
that's what sales is all about it's
pretty simple so if you're not talking
to strangers
you're not making more money you cannot
be making more money
marketing is putting your offer putting
your story putting your product
in front of people that who didn't know
you before they've never heard of you
before
that's called marketing who are these
people they're all
strangers so that's what i'm talking
about so you got to be comfortable so
a few things that i did number one as an
introvert
i joined toastmasters i learned how to
speak in public to get out of my comfort
zone so that i can
be a little bit more comfortable talking
to people i forced
i forced myself to go to networking
functions to go to business functions
to talk to people to learn to ask
questions even though it was
uncomfortable but i knew i need to get
out of my comfort zone
so now through training and through
conditioning that i could
be an extrovert when necessary now most
of the time i'm still very private
right i could be in my room just
thinking and doing and brainstorming
and reading whole day and not talking to
a single person the whole day
and i'm very comfortable with just being
by myself
or i could go out there and i could talk
to a huge group of audience or even
connecting with you on social media
i'm perfectly okay as well so it's
trained
don't feel like oh this is who i am yes
by nature you're naturally more maybe
more like an introvert
but through time through skills through
training
you could expand your comfort zone rule
number three push
through failures so just because the
pieces fail
it doesn't mean you fail they're two
different things
what it means is maybe you're lacking
some
skills to make the business work that's
it's like let's think about this
how many doors you were knocked on so do
you knock on
two doors and you get a no and you say
man i can never do sales
i'm not a good salesman forget this man
forget it
oh is it just because you don't make the
sale
no different if you think your business
as a sale
you got your first note you knock on
that first door
you get a first note then what do you do
as a sales person
next door and you get a no again
but then how many doors you knock until
you get a yes
and then once you get that yes it makes
up all the losses
it doesn't matter how many times no one
cares about my 13 failures
once you made it nobody cares no i do
share
because i think that inspires people but
nobody cares did you ever have like uh
like a point like seventh or eighth time
after that business like man maybe
like maybe i should you know go back to
target or like you know what i mean like
of course i would be lying if i say no
yeah right but
you just can't but it wasn't motivation
though
it's because i was lose i lost so much
money in the businesses
in order to pay it back i had to make it
work so i knew i couldn't pay back
if i just worked for someone else
because i was
by the time the 13 business failures i
was 150 000
in debt wow 150k 20 years old
borrowed from family and friends and
credit card so
how am i going to pay that off making 2
3k a month
forget it so i had to make it work i can
tell you if the 14th one didn't work
it doesn't matter because compared to
other i look at other people
i ask myself and you should ask yourself
am i dumber than everybody else do i
work less hot than everybody else
if they can make it why not you so i ask
myself very honest i work harder than
anybody else
i i'll work and i'll learn and outsmart
them and i do
rule number four double down on your
learning
double down on your learning you see
most people during
time of self-isolation what do they do
they watch netflix they watch tv they
play video games
that's their choice but wouldn't it be
smarter
to not take these times that you
normally wouldn't have
go listen to that podcast watch more
educational videos
learning take some courses online learn
from other people
read a book read a kindle do something
to upgrade your skills
now is the time to learn
now is not the time to waste time see
the world kind of
at the moment kind of freeze everything
kind of slows down
everybody slows down now it's time for
you to prepare yourself
emotionally but also mentally as well
so that when things return back to
kind of normal you're there
you're prepared it's very very critical
don't waste time hi this is dan lok i
want to share with you a
lesson from evan carl michael's new book
build
to serve this section is about making
money from your purpose
you have to embrace that if you never
learn how to make money from your
purpose
you always end up needing a day job and
your purpose will become
a hobby if that sounds like a great life
to you
then i'm happy for you if not then you
need to figure out a money-making model
that makes sense one that is consistent
one that
is significant one that can pay you so
you can quit your job and succeed
to the point where you are providing
jobs for others
and helping even more people you see
money is nothing more than a byproduct
of value creation the more people that
you serve the more successful that you
will be
so to have long-term success it's not
just build a lot
or or build to sell or even build a
scale it is
built to serve and this book will teach
you exactly
how to do that rule number five focus on
the speed
most entrepreneurs how many of you fish
any anyone fishes here
likes fishing great great most
entrepreneurs what they do they fish
they try to get customers they try to
get leads they go online they go to
networking
or they go to an event like this try to
get deals trying to get opportunities
but sometimes they actually they're
fishing in the wrong lake
they're fishing in the wrong spot the
people they're looking for
the customers the clients are looking
for they're actually not in that lake
they're fishing the wrong place they're
selling to the wrong market is that
possible yes or no
it's possible or here's how they fish
most the time
they fish with a spear so they look
they look and try to catch one oh
damn and they try to catch one oh
spend a lot of time hunting looking
right or sometimes a little bit better
they try to fish with like a
one fish hook with no bake though
because whatever they're selling is not
very compelling so
you know what happens when you fish with
no bait all right
it becomes it's not a fishing game it's
a sitting game
you see for a long time right if you're
a little bit
better a little bit better you'll get a
little baked what the fish likes to eat
and then you catch a fish right
that's how most people do it would you
like to know how i do it
here's how i fish
remember this i don't fish with the
spear
i want multiple fishing rods
on a boat and i want hundreds of these
boats
i don't want to fish one at time because
it's not efficient it is too
slow write it down money
loves speed
it's easy to grow faster than to grow
slower
it's easy to scale faster than the scale
slow rule number six cut the
non-essential spending
now it's time to go lean groceries
mortgage your rent yes we need all that
but what about the other expenses do we
actually need the cable tv
right if you have netflix maybe you
don't need cable tv
right you look at all those expenses
maybe
that big vacation that you were planning
to take now you have the extra cash
put that in your emergency fund that big
home renovations that you were thinking
now you're gonna delay them that new car
you're gonna buy
delayed it cut all non-essential
spendings period rule number seven set
expectations if you're single
make sure you have that conversation
early up front
in the beginning the lust takes over i
get it we're all humans
right you better very early on in a
dating stage
have the conversation with your
girlfriend honey i'm gonna become
wealthy
it's my number one focus are you on
board
are you not on board if she thinks
you're crazy
it's not gonna work you gotta find a new
one
you gotta have someone and say good i'll
i'll support you on that
so i set expectations this is who i am
this is what i'm striving for i'm not a
typical
boyfriend i'm very busy i'm working on
my business
if you expect certain things you expect
from most boyfriends
i'm not your guy early upfront
set expectations rule number eight
solidify your offer
you see when it comes to generating
revenue online or
scaling your business on the internet
there are only two things
you need to pay attention to number one
is your traffic
[Music]
and then it's your conversion which is
your funnel your sales process
everything that you do your offer your
pricing so you have your traffic
and then you have your conversion well
it's no good to just
try to drive traffic to your website if
your offer
doesn't convert attention traffic
eyeballs don't pay bills you need to be
able to have
an offer that converts so how do you
solidify your offer first
you want to have something that actually
works then you can run some paid traffic
doesn't matter if it's instagram
facebook google depends on who you're
targeting to
and you want to run some traffic to that
offer to make sure that it actually
sells to make sure it converts visitors
that's coming in to buyers
that's the very first step you need to
be able to do that rule number nine
take calculated risks if you have
identified the needs and the demand
already
now you just need to think about i
wonder
what product i could create to help them
solve that particular problem
now you have minimized your risk or
if there's a huge marketplace out there
that's being created by
other people a smarter entrepreneur
would be thinking how can i kind of ride
that wave
how can i tap into that example instead
of you trying to come up with
the next thing to maybe compete with
apple the next
iphone you know steve jobs i know steve
jobs
chances are that's not going to happen
but you could probably have a very
decent business
to sell iphone cases you might have a
very decent business
to sell maybe both a protective shield
that protects people's iphone so you
think about
because of a company created such
a massive demand for this particular
product
what are some of the complementary
products that you could sell
right it's like you think about in the
ocean you have the big whale
right the big whale that's swimming in
the ocean you're that little fish
you attach yourself to that big whale
right just
be left over from the big whales alone
you could have a very very successful
and profitable business
without a lot of risk without guessing
well i guess people want it
i guess there might be demand for it no
you know because this is
this marketplace out there there's this
this massive demand that's being created
you just kind of tap into that that's a
very very smart way i call that
chicken entrepreneurship right that you
are like
you're being a little chicken you're a
little bit afraid you're being
conservative
taking not stupid risk but calculate the
risk how can i use the least amount of
money
but get my business going right then
from there once you have accumulated
capital
once you've you kind of have some
success under your belt then you can do
bigger things versus i'm going to invent
the next thing that's going to be
the next iphone better than the iphone
well chances are you're not going to do
that you're not elon musk
you're not steve jobs right let's just
face it and rule number 10 the last time
before very special bonus clip
is have leverage you want to create a
system
that would create those results
predictably
even when you are not there this is
where most entrepreneurs got stuck
because at the zero to million dollar
phase you are
the go-to person chances are you're the
number one sales person
for the company you are the ring maker
you are the one that's connecting with
customers
you know all the customers you have the
relationships
you're bringing in the money you're
doing probably a lot of the work
still at that level but now you can't
because the capacity issue right you hit
that glass ceiling
from 1 to 10 million now you need
systems why do you need systems because
then you can bring in people who are
better than you
that could run those systems to create
the same result
as if you were there from the one to 10
million
and this is what stops most
entrepreneurs because what what got you
to that 1 million
won't get you to that 10 million a lot
of the habits a lot of things that
worked in the past
that you could grind it out you cannot
grind it out
at that new level i always say you could
hustle your way
to six figure you cannot hustle your way
to seven figure
at seven figure you need leverage and
you leverage
people systems processes to create more
results
to create more impact to create more
value in the marketplace
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an
action plan for what you're going to do
you increase it from 35 percent to 91
chance of you actually following through
and when you share your plan
publicly that jumps to 95 chance of
following through so i want that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you now in traffic secrets russell talks
about it which is something that i do as
well
it's called the dream 100 concept what
does that mean
it means that you want to identify and
find 100 dream
partners those who already have the
traffic they could be
an influencer they could be a blogger
they could be a youtuber
someone who already has attention
in the marketplace someone who is
already talking to your ideal customers
what blogs do they read where do they
hang out what videos
they watch they're already paying
attention to these influencers
then the dream 100 concept is simply you
approach them and you say hey you know
what
i've got to prove an offer here right i
am
willing to pay you an affiliate
commission i'm willing to pay you
a certain percentage for every single
sale that you make
so you leverage their existing traffic
because
that's the fastest way to do it right
you're essentially
borrowing that traffic from them you say
hey you've got the audience
you've got your attention i've got a
proven offer can we
work something together it's that simple
once you could do that if your offer
converts and your affiliate partners
your dream 100
they're making money they will be more
than happy to continue to promote
now you're earning more profits you're
earning more money
hi this is dan lok if you're a fan of
evan's work
if you want to know exactly how to model
my
success i want to invite you to join me
for a special online training
all you have to do is click on the link
below you can join me for
absolutely no charge so click the link
below and i will see you
in class
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated
channel just for it go check it out the
link is right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there